olá pessoal de que fala o dark é então o
elegeu os trabalhos de que case
animatrônico é um excelente jogo que
ainda não comprei a case metrô nesse
quesito luiz que ela julga o psi ora
bolas
eu pensava que já não tem boi comando da
pasta quero tudo tá escuro trazer luz
cheio estou fechada está tudo perdido
como é que os jovens agora vou ter que
puxar a chapa de metal nelson martins
costa da tua mãe costa eu quero julgar
por não possuir daqui isso acho que eu
posso eu quero para o meu corpo para lá
eu consiga andar
o ator filho consiga andar com o
personagem
este 3 veículo assim ai ai manter na
jamil está muito bom só vai ter lá oi
está a falhar já meu deus menores close
claro que está sempre certo é quando não
está em uso como é que eu vou desenhar
um quarto que eu quero se está tudo os
docentes a isso será este um alô pra ele
e é mesmo fred eu chamei pelo fred eo
frank gill em que estava a sentir aquele
cheiro a enxofre que esse jogo não
enxofre
ai ai verissinho a eu só sei que tudo aí
o fluxo do robô que [ __ ] 44 a 494 é
isso quase não acho que ela tem que
fazer alguma coisa
doris logo falei que eu acho que a chave
está no quarto 4 944 uma câmera de
segurança alguém está a controlar meu
deus confusão está aqui meu estado está
a funcionar ainda a ló style grey sua
mãe
desculpe pessoal eu estou muito ser eu
estou muito concentrado porque crédito
com uma piada muito assustador esticar
muito entramos agora no office oficial o
frei que este é o chefe o cara quer
sempre o chefe diz que se o pokémon gol
eu odeio o batman porque preocupado mas
lembramos o matheus bateu
será que é isso que tem cativado
a final do cavalo mudou o sistema
induzindo locais possivelmente turno 4º
b 11 horas tossir vigiado bastante de
mim que ela gosta só que supostamente
primeira noite foi só um sonho
importante
eu acho que já posso voltar a sentir o
painel não é não sair no ar eu quem vai
dizer 'este sujo neste momento difícil
não sei que está acontecer [ __ ] não
sei como fazer no sinal porque o dnit
signal aqui na casa do publicitário
eu acho que isso aí 36 mas não sei se
será encarado o sul também é alto 1 é
jonas pinheiro por mexer também no novo
porque eu sou um quadro pois é aqui um
código entre de cultura de dormir eu já
percebi que era um dois três quatro
quilos não é como assim estão estou
quase que toda a gente está aqui o foco
se eu treinar e james sikes tem entre
óleo trecho oi está ligado a um código
41 3028 vai curso foi no cozinho já
perdeu para jacques que este número como
assim que precisava para trás já
esquecido o código 3 728 é strecht 102
83 3218 8537 muito bonito muito triste
aí já me esqueci do corda e canalizamos
que seu pai três 3 728 considera que é
preciso você precisa ativar o iraty
campello vai trocar o pneu outra vez
ativistas fez vez julgado agora já tem
signal iduna tanto né brinca vai da
costa mas eu estou preparado porque eu
sou o saque dos frangos legal para
portinho não dá status do voto como está
a chamar em pizza é [ __ ] piso eu quero
não for da pisa [ __ ] acho que não tive
nessa sala ainda o jogo tão divertido
um é divertido ok é divertido estava a
brincar é mesmo
mesmo após fechar o cinema nas e da
ponte o olho já ouvi por a novidade lá
fora
ana ali qualquer coisa eu não vou lá e
aqui tem disso o [ __ ] tão forte aqui
oi eu acho que destas caixas no ataque
dentro
assim já não possui nada ou não de tal
forma que já não se vê nada disso
oi de robocop meu deus meu deus eu não
não fosse fugiu
ok vamos fazer isso até mesmo é preciso
atender o telefone vai pra quem só tem
só porque agora eles fugiram só agora
ela fosse o aeroporto abriu fugir eles
como na casa de banho
ai meu deus pela ativa isso agora fosse
embora finja que fazem exatamente é isso
mesmo ninguém chuveiro sob anonimato nem
pensar que estava a tomar banho não é
porque o silva a água e agora não sei
que dizer não eu tenho um tablet nem
todo usuário tava que maravilha já não
lembro como é que se sinta dentro do
tablet botafoto muito burro no centro de
itajaí frame e nem confirmou se tem aqui
qualquer coisa eu posso entrar aqui
dentro brutal ou será que é porque eu
tenho que exatamente porque [ __ ]
mostrou uma nova eo arquiteto vivo eu
não sei como posso escolher sumiço a
vida perdeu a data pode pagar até muito
estudo não é muito é muito estudo hoje
ontem do nude e já comi tudo sobre um
grupo que já nem se executa entra o
outro de uma porta onde terá um do psol
é preso canalho [ __ ] você panetone
outros greve que eu não percebo que essa
sala estado russo podem fazer os jogos
em inglês por favor
o u1 qualquer coisa dentro desta caixa
eu não sei o que é mas parece muito
grande né uma coisa muito grande para o
que se passa é minha lanterna é que eu
vou ficar sem pilha ótimo ótimo é assim
mesmo que eu gosto de joguinhos e sem
pilha é com fred já solta é contudo eu
tô sem sair na quinta as portas estão
todas fechadas sem preocupação da
estátua do bahia sempre a passar o
convite
continuou perdido para cuba
depois foi embora agora eu percebi que o
número mais que fugir vai agora sair mas
sem muitos filhos senhor nem se muito
silva eo a 10 em itajaí norte põe seu
viper serei ok vamos deixar o senhor
fred passará pela praça la paz a passar
a coroa é muito estudo mil cápsulas já
foi embora agora vamos tentar achar
qualquer coisa para fazer que não faço
por dinheiro do que tem que fazer ainda
mas também pelo brio esta porta esta
sala né e o que vou te encontrar alguma
coisa hoje sobre uma das gavetas estão
vazias tipo não a [ __ ] nenhuma aqui
olha outra por toque
estava eu fui virão do acho que vai pra
que anuncia o início aqui e nos poucos
talentos 18
eu acho que você sabe que estou cá olha
vou andar em frente [ __ ] se eu não sei
que tenho que dizer que hoje à tarde o
fundo lembra engordou
vamos aproveitar que eu tava ao fundo e
tenta explorar e que esta parte o urso
no tablet km o que eu posso dizer agora
sem pilhas que explique o que eu posso
dizer sim picchu aberta fechou a porta e
apague as luzes todas calma calma não
acho que vai passar aqui e está cada vez
mais perto
já estamos em quem é funk estão jornada
o console será que eu sabe que eu estou
aqui em alto ave
eu só vi que ela foge pô los para uso
pessoal vamos ficar com isso espero que
vocês tenham gostado eu sei eu sei que
eu sou muito burro eu não sei bem o tabu
de não sair bem na luz eu não sei por
que eu tenho que fazer ali e por isso
mesmo com a passagem do pessoal comentei
nos comentários coisas para eu fazer o
que eu tenho de fazer aqui explicando
depois que eu tenho já sabem quanto como
a selic favorito fique bem até a próxima